well if you've ever had an extreme bond
with an animal which I know I have so I
can relate today's show it's one that
you want to stay tuned for our guests
today are the team behind a beautiful
documentary the wild parrots of
Telegraph Hill director Judy Irving and
the doc star Mark Bittner join us via
telephone to discuss this film yeah I'm
just really grateful to that we have
this duel on the line here to talk to us
today and and really this story was
inspired and you know let's talk about
the beginnings of how this all came to
be because you know we we one day we're
just hearing all these bird sounds
outside of our house and all throughout
our neighborhood you had you had gone
from a walk here and you come back to
tell a little bit about the background
of how this came to be we were actually
doing ADR for goodbye promise and so
there were these birds in the background
that we could hear and I went for a walk
and I saw all of these green parrots on
this this telephone line and so I began
to Google it and that's when it sparked
my memory about the dock and so I said
why don't we call them up and get them
on the show yeah and they've been
gracious enough to join us really
excited and according to Box Office Mojo
the wild parrots of Telegraph Hill ranks
as the 48th highest-grossing documentary
film the film spotlights mark veterinary
musician who had shunned the corporate
world living a life of voluntary
simplicity sometimes homeless and
sometimes employed with various odd jobs
who finds meaning and a flock of wild
parrots that inhabit the trees outside
his apartment where he stayed as a
caretaker mark viewed his time with the
parrots as a diversion from his worries
instead finding that the parrots were
part of his true calling he formed a
deep relationship with the birds
despite battles from the city and
filmmaker Judy Irving contacted mark
making the documentary and eventually
changing both of their lives we have two
guest hosts joining us here in studio
today who traveled all the way from New
York we are screening their film cerise
tomorrow night at the Downtown
independent Mary Nell Mont Ellis has
worked as a production designer set
director and she is also the marketing
mind behind cerise helping the film
become one of the early success stories
on IndieGoGo raising I believe 60 $300
on a five thousand dollar goal and you
can follow her blog at Mary Nell
tumblr.com
and also on Twitter at Mary Nell our
other guest host today says he is a poet
primarily John Titor gonna says
published work in a variety of poetry
and literary journals all over the world
in 2007 he was the nominee for a
pushcart prize in poetry John has
written and directed seven shorts
including cerise speed musing perfect
the hotel Edwards and the coconut and
don't know if a lot of you know about
this yet we'd like to congratulate John
for just inking a deal to author the
upcoming book The Tao of crowdfunding
you can follow John's journey by
visiting John char go nice calm and
follow him on twitter at trigonis there
we are yeah we're super thrilled to have
you guys the studio with us today is
amazing so far and I want you to do me a
favor I want you guys to stay close to
the mic because I want to make sure that
not only can we hear you whatever you
want you gotta stay uncomfortably close
we like to say well I'm pretty
uncomfortable let us welcome to film
courage Judy Irving and Mark Bittner
hello thank you for joining us for more
on Judea mark please visit Pelican media
org and to keep up with Mark's writings
please visit mark Bittner dotnet Judy
we'll start with you first how large of
an influence did your grandfather have
on you and becoming a filmmaker
that's an interesting question my
grandfather had a huge influence on me
becoming a bird lover he taught me all
about Birds when I was about seven eight
years old and he showed me that I could
actually hand feed tickety's in the
backyard if I held my hands very still
my palm open it was really magical to
feel those tiny little feet on my
fingers when I was at
the the filmmaking part actually came
more from my father who worked for NBC
television in New York he was a started
out of the cameraman and then he became
a technical director and I grew up
hanging out on the sets of the Johnny
Carson show and so forth before he moved
to LA so I I was used to thinking about
shots and angles and and camera and
sound and all of that from my dad okay
interesting
tell us your thought process before you
roll camera on a new project what
elements have to be there in order for
you to invest your talents in a movie I
have to really love the subject and in
many cases that has to do with birds I
have made a lot of environmental issue
films and but they're always character
based and they always have birds in them
I think I think birds as avian
ambassadors are really the critters that
we urban people see most and so because
of that lots of people have experience
with birds and it's it's easy to get
across information and issues and and
just important things about the natural
world via birds so I have to really like
the subject and be interested to find
out more about it myself I think of the
documentary process as the process of
research and you know digging up
information about things rather than
knowing everything before you roll the
camera you know Judy speaking of
something else you don't have I mean
what's fascinating about your process is
that when you begin you know you don't
have a script you know you have you you
know and you often have little or no
budget so you were you are really diving
into the unknown but so so once you do
die
how do you begin to craft the story and
and how do you sort of know what what
you're gonna film next well a lot of a
lot of film teachers would probably
shudder at how I do this but mmm I you
know I do a little bit of research at
the beginning and then I I dive in and I
start shooting and it's way before I
have full funding I do not have I do not
go from a script I don't necessarily my
style is not talking heads and b-roll
mice that's a that's a style that's
derived from news reporting and I'm not
it's not particularly interesting as a
movie style but a lot of people use it
in documentaries and my style is more
like okay what scene can i film and how
does the scene have a beginning middle
and end it's more of a dramatic
structure that I'm searching for I'm
searching for characters and I'm
searching for a conflict etc the same
kinds of things that you folks who know
all about fiction filmmaking are looking
for in a script but in this case there
is no script so you're and you're
basically pulling it from reality
you're taking it from what's actually
happening and you're trying to surf that
wave of the present tense to find a
story that's unfolding now this is this
is what I like to do anyway a lot lots
of folks make films about historical
events that are completely in the past
and then of course you'd have to go
about it in a different way but for a
contemporary issue or a contemporary
person or a contemporary story you've
got to just dive in and try to make
sense of it as you go and in that regard
Judy I mean are do you manipulate it
ever I mean do you ever try to you know
since you are looking for the beginning
middle and end of a scene or do you ever
try to say hey will you just do this or
are
kind of captured the moment in that
regard and now well you can't really
manipulate it on a grand scale
you could occasionally ask somebody you
know could you just come in that door
again or whatever if you blew the shot
that's that to me is not you know
morally suspect but no I don't
manipulate the story at all I just try
to find it and uncover it and cover it
as it as it happens so you you remain
objective and you remain the observer
yeah yeah I do I mean in the case of the
wild parrots of Telegraph Hill I just
happened to call mark and see him
feeding the birds and get started on the
movie nine months before he had to move
and before that essentially you know
although it was unfortunate for mark it
created a very interesting dramatic arc
and ending for the film when he had to
leave so that I I couldn't know you know
but it happened while I was filming and
Judy one thing I wanted to know you know
what once you start a project I mean
have you ever you know gone into this
process since you don't know where
what's gonna happen next necessarily I
mean have you ever abandoned a project I
know not really I mean you can always
figure something out each each project
to me sort of the material itself tells
you how to edit it and what what you
need to do to bring out the best story
for example there was a fabulous old
Italian American based swimmer open
water swimmer that I wanted to do a film
about and he had died already and I had
been filming him over eight years at the
South End rowing club where I swim in
the bay
so I had to figure out a structure for
that film where the sequences went back
and forth he had already died in one
sequence where folks were having a
memorial a very funny memorial for him
with stories about him and everything
and then back to footage where he was
already alive and he was having setting
records and having a heart attack in the
water and all kinds of things that I was
able to get so in that film the big
challenge was time sequence in the Paris
film the big issue was the relationship
between mark and the birds and how that
developed how the characters came to be
known both to him and to the audience so
I I think what I would say is that the
material itself in documentary
filmmaking the materials itself that
you're gathering kind of if you're open
to it and your intuitive enough tells
you how to edit it tells you what the
structure should be as you work through
it I just had a quick question actually
coming from a storyteller point of view
is there ever a moment when you kind of
didn't figure out what the story behind
something was where you were actually
shooting footage you know in the hopes
of telling the story but then eventually
it came out that there really wasn't any
because I know as a writer without
spending any money on shooting that
would be like a nightmare to me if I
couldn't figure out where this thing was
going so I just kind of was curious how
you handle that or if it's ever happened
to you right well there are dead ends
that you take definitely you follow out
certain threads and in a film that I
worked on about the nuclear issue for
instance nuclear weapons and nuclear
power and there at the impact of the
industry on ordinary human beings there
were several threads that we followed
one of them being radiant contamination
that went nowhere and so that just
becomes outtakes that's all I mean in
the days when I was shooting films 16
millimeter
film yes that was an expensive lesson to
learn but it's also part of trying to
uncover that's the subject and to end do
your research via the filmmaking so yeah
you just have to turn away from those
paths that don't lead you anywhere
I'll wondering to Judy where does your
tenacity come from I mean from raising
funding for your films to the years that
you spend invested making them why don't
you give up well first of all you have
to start if you're going to get into a
process like this where you're where
you're kind of learning about a subject
or learning about a person or learning
about a place via the filmmaking you
have to start with something that you're
really really interested in and then
that interest that curiosity keeps you
going also the fact that you have
amassed a certain amount of footage
you've amassed a certain amount of
information about the subject storyline
is beginning to develop you know that
kind of thing you also don't want to
disappoint your early funders there's
all kinds of reasons to keep going I
think that one of the most important
aspects one of the most important
personality characteristics of
filmmakers both fiction and nonfiction
is tenacity persistence if you don't
have it you're not going to make it
because an awful lot of these projects
I'm sure you can all vouch for this take
many many years to get done so you just
don't know maybe it's a personality
trait that you already have it and then
you become a filmmaker
they certainly go hand-in-hand Judy take
us to the wild parrots of Telegraph Hill
how did you hear of these parrots and
and sort of and then what kind of drew
you to mark at the
time yeah well I had first seen the
parrots when I was swimming in the bay
they were overhead squawking like crazy
flying past aquatic park in San
Francisco and then I had a cockatiel my
own little pet bird and I was reading
bird talk magazine one dot one day and I
read an article that mark has written
about his relationship with the parrots
that was in 1995 years and years before
I started the movie and then later to
friends I had made a film about blue
herons at Golden Gate Park just the kids
film with a little short kids film when
I showed that there was a birder in the
audience and he said oh you got to make
a film about this guy who feeds the
parrots and a friend who worked at the
library had also told me the same thing
so I felt like okay these two friends
are telling me the same thing I better
call this guy up so that's how it
happened
friends pointed me in the right
direction and I went over there and saw
him feeding them and thought oh this is
this is pretty great you know that the
birds are very colorful but I'm not sure
about mark that was my first impression
interesting so when you first started
filming parrots was the core idea to
film the story of the birds or was it
more to tell Mark's story
it was both okay it was to make a movie
about Mark's relationship with the birds
and Mark was indispensable because he is
a great storyteller and he knew the
birds and he knew their personalities
could describe them and as I got to hear
more and more of these stories I
realized oh if I could film those
particular birds doing those things or
whatever or being cuddly with each other
like he talks about Picasso and Sophie
for instance then I then I could get the
beginnings of a good movie here so it
was it was both right from the start was
the relationship between
a person and these wild creatures right
in the city now mark prior to Judah you
must have had hundreds of tourists than
locals who snapped photos of you with
the parrots and there must have been you
know among those I'm sure those get
capturing you on video what what made
Judy stand out amongst the others
well not nervous she was the first
serious person I mean I was hoping
somebody would come along because I want
I knew I was going to end it at a
certain point and I wanted to have a
visual record because it was so visual
just something to keep little souvenirs
so to speak and there was one guy who
came along he no two people came along
and we're both interested in shooting
videos and that was all I was looking
for and that was fine but in both cases
the project fell through and then she
came along and she had a track record
and she was more serious and you know I
didn't know where it was gonna go
neither one of us did but I trusted her
and so you know whatever she wanted to
do was fun and and they just kept
developing from originally she was just
gonna make a short little film and then
she's gonna make a kid's film short kids
film and then I just kept developing
into what it finally became and how did
she first approached you and and and
what made you comfortable because that's
always what I wonder and anytime there's
a documentary film and you're dealing
with you know you're dealing with people
it's like you know when a stranger comes
in and says I want to put you on camera
you know I you know I would be
apprehensive myself so I always wonder
how other people handle it well I wasn't
nervous about the camera because I had a
friend who was a film student and she
had me at the lead in two little
experimental films she made so that was
that that didn't bother me when she
called me it felt fine to me although I
started getting nervous
in the interim before she actually
showed up because I didn't know I mean I
was living an unusual lifestyle
you know very few people actually ever
came inside my house and saw what was
going on and I was a little bit nervous
but you know he seemed mature she was
adults so you know I just relaxed and
worried about it and what do you
remember of that first encounter well I
had this house business records and you
know and the place was damp it's against
the hill said it was a very old building
you can't really tell this in the film
but I mean the walls were moist it had a
smell of mold and but it was free you
know that's one reason I was living
there it was it was a roof so I remember
her coming in and I remember her being
actually quite even level about it but I
guess she was more surprised she sure it
just been fine he just seemed adult
that's all mm-hmm thank you
and then Judy you have a sort of a
paraphrase quote about Mark that I
wanted to read because it really struck
me and you said he didn't want to be on
a career path the parents were a
diversion when you start doing something
you love look carefully at it because it
might just be your path can you expand
on that yeah I think often people
discard what they really love to do and
they feel that that's not important or
it's not what they should be doing or
it's not you know maybe doesn't make
enough money but if you really love
doing it you might want to look more
carefully at it because you'll have the
energy and the tenacity and the interest
to possibly make it into something that
can really work for you more than just a
hobby or a diversion and in marks case
he was sort of reading a lot of
philosophy and Eastern philosophy and
philosophy and history and all kinds of
things and trying to figure out the
meaning of life and and then these birds
came visiting and his Jack there and he
started feeding them and just kept
telling himself oh I've got to stop this
this is too time-consuming it's so much
fun and I'm learning so much about these
birds but this is just a diversion this
is not this is not helping my search my
spiritual search my philosophical search
and so and then and and Mark you should
probably be talking about this yourself
you know I had well I was I sort of left
everything in 1973 and I spent the next
14 years essentially without an address
no home and then I got this I landed
this thing as caretaking as a caretaker
of this big house and so it seemed like
okay I've been struggling along for 14
years I need to really get serious
because I won't have this forever and I
mean the next time I have to go out
there I want to know which way I'm going
and then these parrots came along and at
first I saw them as a diversion but they
were an enjoyable diversion but as I got
pulled deeper into it I mean I just kept
finding resonances that were really
helpful to me in general and you know
there's to me there's you know I know a
lot of people don't believe this kind of
stuff but there's no doubt in my mind
that I was supposed to do this and it
changed everything in my life it was
like it was a door I walked through and
everything improved everything got
better for me and the answered questions
that I had about how the mind works I
was able to start making a living in a
way that I wanted to I learned all kinds
of things skills come I know I was I was
completely outside of the computer world
I didn't know anything about computers I
had no idea what they even did and
because of them I was writing a books
and we said oh well you'll need a
computer
and I didn't even understand what he
meant by that so but he gave me his old
computer and so I got into that so I
mean they really did change everything
that I was going through and you know
it's worked out very well for me
so what looked to me like a diversion
turned out not to be at all
and it was something that I was just
loving doing I mean I looked at them as
friends I didn't look at them as
anything else really I mean once I
started I wrote a book and once I
started getting into the research of the
book I started getting more a little
more scientific about it or at least I
started going to science type books to
understand more about certain things but
first and foremost they were always
friends to me and that's how I enjoyed
them now you were a musician for many
years and you said you reached a point
where you realize that it wasn't in you
to have that as a path how did you come
to this decision and what was it about
being a music that it just wasn't in you
well that's actually a little bit
inaccurate but that's how the story's
been told over the years I'm working on
a book right now which will clarify all
this but I hadn't wanted to be a
musician for a long time but I had a big
conflict inside of myself as to whether
I really was a musician or not I have
the feeling that certain people are born
to do certain things I have some ability
as a musician but I wasn't really
passionate about it I guess you'd say
and I kept trying to find the devotion I
needed discipline I needed to be a good
musician but I couldn't do it so finally
push came to shove I went out and tried
it and I found rather quickly that it
was a mistake I wasn't a musician it
just was you know wasn't the center of
my love but the time that I was growing
up and musicians were like you know the
singer-songwriter was sort of regarded
as the poet of the time and that
appealed to me a lot I wanted to be one
of those I wanted to have something to
say and the idea was that people were
saying it through music then so I wanted
to get into that but it just wasn't
really what I was born to do so I had to
leave all of that behind it really only
took me about seven or eight months for
the whole thing to come crashing down I
was serious about for seven or eight
months and then it fell apart so and I
actually was making a living at it but
it was just driving me crazy it wasn't
it wasn't satisfying me and you say that
the parrots were your friends so we want
to talk about something that you touch
on in the film and that
is attributing you know human
characteristics to an animal right and
you said that they fear death they get
jealous they love they mourn and that
these birds have these emotions that we
all feel and you know anyone who's ever
been close to an animal can attest to
this but there's so many out there who
feel that this is not true and that you
know their brains are smaller than ours
can you dispel these myths I don't think
I can change him Betty's mind I think an
experience it's really the only thing
that's gonna change most people's minds
but you know I think that
characteristics character are universal
I mean it's Universal to mind see we
have this there are sort of like three
views of existence now one is the
scientific view which says it's all just
physics and chemistry there's the
creator god idea where there was this
god that created material and some of
it's alive and some of its not and then
there's the everything is God idea and
you know the mind is there everything is
the mind the whole universe is the mind
and that's the one I subscribe to so you
know all of these characteristics are
present in existence and all living
creatures partake of these same
characteristics they're not exclusive
human beings human beings might have
more characteristics they have a broader
range but you know they exist in animal
animals identically I mean that it's all
recognizable to you as a human being
what they're going through a lot of the
time sometimes not because they have
different biological concerns they don't
store food for example so they have to
be constantly looking for food so I'm
sure that motivates them to do certain
things that might be a little bit more
difficult to understand but when you see
jealousy and when you see rage when you
see humor I mean they're they're very
funny and it's all very transparent when
you're actually dealing with it one on
one so I realized after a while that
the problem is not answered for morphism
its answer for centrism we human beings
think we're the center you know God's
gift to the world that kind of thing
it's and it's just not true yeah and I
think Judy you had mentioned in a prior
interview that watching the film may
actually help someone overcome feelings
of loneliness or depression knowing that
we're just such a small part in this big
picture right and it's not to try to
diminish us but to try to enlarge our
understanding of the universe beyond
just human concerns I think a lot of
people particularly folks who live in
cities are lonely and it's easy to be
lonely in a city it's easy to just look
down at the concrete or up at the
electric wires and think you know what's
the use kind of thing but if you get
yourself if you just get yourself out
there into nature and look around a
little bit you'll see that there are
there's a whole world out there really
literally that we've kind of forgotten
about most people have forgotten about
and if you open yourself up to it it's
just not only is a more accurate view of
the world that we live in but it also
makes you feel better to know that we
share this planet with all these
creatures and then you start feeling
well you know God I have I have a
responsibility to try to make sure that
these other critters do okay I'm making
a film right now
about California brown pelicans it's
actually my favorite bird and it's
called Pelican dreams and as I film
these individual pelicans that I'm
getting to know in a variety of contexts
and also more general sequences at their
breeding grounds and
and grounds and so forth in Southern
California the Channel Islands I'm
realizing that you know as people fall
in love with pelicans through the film
they're also going to fall in love with
the coast the whole West Coast because
that's where pelicans live so it's all
interconnected and it broadens your your
view and it makes you feel a part of
something bigger mark I'm wondering how
did you handle the death of these
various birds that had come to be your
friends well that was very difficult for
me at first actually because I think I
say that in the movie but I for some
strange reason and I'd been noticing it
for years I never had a friend or it was
someone who was close to me died that
had just stayed away from me for years
and years I was in my 40s by the time
that finally happened to me and it was
the death of a bird and it was
devastating you know it it really tore
me apart because I loved that little
bird I'd put that's two pillows yeah put
years no excuse me I'd put months into
that bird scare it was dying but I
didn't really see that but they live
shorter lives as we do and eventually I
did get used to it at first it was very
hard for me and I think it had a lot to
do with the level of concern and care I
was putting into it
mm-hmm thank you I mean you call of this
energy in to try and keep something
alive and then it dies you know this
this is film courage I know they talk
radio calm our guests today are Judy
Irving and Mark Bittner of the film the
wild parrots of Telegraph Hill we are
joined in studio by our guest hosts Mary
Nell Montes and John trigonis and
they're just kind of taken in the whole
experience you know Marc the mainstream
I'm just gonna take an opposite approach
here for a second the mainstream kind of
grooms
from the time were little to make these
career decisions to work tirelessly at
it and then retire but instead you chose
something else you chose to study
alternative methods of thinking and
philosophy and Eastern religions why is
that
well I one day I was walking down the
street and I I was suffering or the loss
of a girl this was when I was 14 years
old well I thought I was and I was just
and I was just devastated I was feeling
down her and down her and I started
looking around me I don't know why I'm
it just my mind started looking at the
houses around me was a suburban mall
type area and it suddenly seemed to me
that that was not the cause of my sorrow
ultimately the sorrow was the emptiness
of the world I was growing up then and I
had a feeling all my life that you know
we we know that we have this one chance
to live and it should be a rich
experience instead it's just this mind
numbing thing that you know like all my
my parents were just saying uh stop
thinking that way just you know do it
you know go to school get a job that's
what life's really about and I didn't
believe it and that day as I was walking
through all of these houses and feeling
just this deep deep misery I said no I I
just can't be the way and I just swore
to myself that I was not going to let
myself live that way I didn't know what
that meant I mean it really was a matter
of saying you know every time I'd come
to a branch in the road
where it was career and all of that or
pinked look for something more alive I
just took the road that was more alive
and wasn't a plan it I don't think
anybody ever really plans that kind of
thing it just it's what I could handle
psychologically I could not handle the
idea of becoming a mummy sir
it felt like to me so I just kept going
that way and another thing that sir I
actually I think is very important was
the counterculture was alive at that
time it's very strong
and there was a feeling you know there
were a lot of people out there trying to
live alternative lives and there were a
little alternative bids businesses so it
didn't feel like such a long shot it
didn't feel like it was something you
were doing all by yourself out on your
own and I think since the collapse of
the counterculture it's a lot harder but
you know it has to happen again because
I don't think the way of life like you
know we keep using the word sustainable
it is not sustainable we cannot keep
living along those lines mark you know
what when does life change you know
because it feels you know at least I
don't know if it's our our age or just
the fact that we are trying to pursue
you know there's you know our ourselves
trying to pursue filmmaking so many
people listen to the show trying to
trying to pursue filmmaking but but it
feels like now more than ever that life
is filled with uncertainty you know
especially when you're going after
life's passion you don't know what's
around the corner if you're ever going
to get there and for you after living
years of living homeless Lee you know as
a homeless and and and not having this
steady career path you know what what
made the difference what was there a
defining moment that made that
difference well I think there were
series of moments see I think my my own
faith is that if you live for what's
really real inside of yourself you hook
up with where you should be and there is
a way of making it other than you know
the usual career paths
so I mean I've had a very unusual story
I'd you know I recognize that but I had
to take a lot of chances
it would seem from the outside that
looks people I think like I've taken a
lot of risks but I don't feel that way I
don't I just just like I you know I kept
doing what I liked and when the going
got tough I just hung in there because I
just couldn't handle doing something I
didn't like I think that's part of it
you know I I get bored with stuff that
doesn't mean anything to me and I just
can't imagine living a life that I don't
love I mean I only have this one chance
here that's the thing that keeps coming
back to me so I'd but I don't think it's
a crapshoot in the sense of luck I think
that if you do what is really your thing
that was an expression everybody had you
know do your thing but if you do what's
really your thing what's really true
inside of you it hooks up with whatever
you need to make it work that's a really
hard thing to accept I think especially
right now because we've come to an
extreme we're in an extreme materialist
time where that kind of thing seems like
a fantasy to people and we're also
addicted to the idea of getting more but
I think I think it when a little bit
farther down the line we're gonna see
that this is a real historical turning
point this time right now that we're in
that's why things feel so strange I
don't think we're going to go back to
what has been considered normal I don't
think it's possible when reading the
comments on Amazon for the film this one
man put a very interesting comment and
he said that he applauded you and he
said that he made much more money than
he felt he was really entitled to and he
wished that he could give it all up and
search for something that satisfied him
but he didn't have enough time and he
didn't want to give up that status so
what would you say to someone like that
well you know what I would say but it
would be too glib is we'll just do it
that's you know it's very hard for me
too I never advise anybody to do what I
did because it has to be done from
inside of them you know you cannot it's
like sending somebody over a cliff if if
they went ahead and did it because you
told them to do it but they have to want
to do it themselves
I think circumstance was going to force
people to live a different kind of life
pretty soon I think it's starting to do
that now yeah you know it's there's the
matter of we're running out of resources
we've got these huge debts we have this
bad
Imperial system so this military thing
spread all around the globe and it's
unsustainable but also I think
psychologically the way we're living you
get up and you you know just do all of
this stuff all day long and then you get
some entertainment at me and a day and
crash we can't it's not sustainable you
can't keep living that way we're not as
living beings were meant to do something
else
and this is what we've been living is a
diversion and you know eventually we're
gonna get forced into doing stuff that
matters and that's fine I mean but it
may feel like pressure for a while I'm a
little bit apocalyptic I think in my
thinking but I think the times bearing
it out actually you know let's come back
to these parrots for a moment martyr you
know I have something else you know that
I find pretty interesting here you know
you mentioned in the documentary that
something that you wanted to do or I
don't know if it was in the documentary
or it might have been in an interview
you wanted to make the bird so famous
that it would be harder for them to lose
some of their rights in the talk of the
radicals wanted to get rid of the birds
because they were a non-native species
you know and what at what point did
those kind of thoughts enter your mind
and and what gave you the confidence
that that goal could ever be achieved
okay first of all I want to correct one
thing that you had in the introduction
you said that he said something about my
having to fight with the city or
struggle with the city the city actually
has been very helpful in all of this but
I think it's partly because of their
fame I I was told by a there was a guy
studying a flock of parrots in Chicago
and he'd been following what I'd been
doing I had a little website for a while
there was no book no film there's just
this little website and he'd been
following it and said well you know one
thing you need to do is you need to make
these birds famous because a lot of
these flocks of parrots there's a lot of
flocks all across the United States it's
not
just San Francisco in LA they're
everywhere well they're not everywhere
but they're in quite a few places so he
said you need to make them famous
because there are organizations that are
opposed to all non-native species and
the flock that he was setting had been
under a lot of pressure from the state
they wanted to exterminate them so he
said if you make them famous that will
be you know it will harder for them to
do that's what convinced me to write a
book actually
and then when Judy came along with the
idea to do a film you know I didn't
really I couldn't say oh yeah well I'll
make a feature-length film that he got
in theaters that wasn't my thought but
anything that could make the birds
present for other people could only help
I figured so it was a gradual process
but that's indeed what did happen they
are little celebrities here in the city
you know nobody's going to be able to
order their extermination you know the
the idea as to whether that's right or
not whether they should be here because
they're non-native I is a whole other
argument and I fall on a particular side
of it but their fame was my hope was
that it would create the situation that
they are now in where they're you know
beloved so nobody's going to come along
and try to get rid of them like saying
you know tearing down the Golden Gate
Bridge at this point or something in the
topic of Fame how are you handling your
own celebrity well it's fading you know
it was funny I have always sort of I
wanted to be famous when I wanted to be
a musician and then when I got out of
that I said well that's ridiculous
wanting to be famous it's a terrible
thing to want to be so I've been through
both sides of it and then you know my
fame I don't even consider it Fame but
you know if people do recognise me on
the street and people are always nice
but you see that it's really we have
this idea of Fame in the culture which
is really kind of bizarre people respond
to me I used to be a guy on the street
and people would you know treat me like
dirt and then now I'm sort of like this
sometimes I get treated like a little
prince and it doesn't make any sense you
know I'm the same person so I mean that
doesn't happen a lot but it does happen
occasionally you notice that something's
different you know you know Judy we're
in our final seconds I mean did you ever
imagine the wild parrots of Telegraph
Hill what would have the impact that
it's had no I didn't but I'm very glad
that it did thank you we'd like to thank
you so much Judy and Mark for taking the
time to share your stories with us you
know I've been watching the film on
Amazon now every night for the past few
days and just really loved it and thank
you so much for agreeing to be in again
thank you means a lot yeah thank you ya
know we loved having you and we let me
know we love them just hear more about
your story and just talking life and
philosophy and just soaking this all in
and keep going with film courage it's
great oh thank you all we appreciate
that means a lot yeah all right oh thank
you
it means a lot that you two would join
us here today you know we also like to
thank our guest holes today that I just
really just wanted to soak in the
experience to be in the studio
john trevaunance and marinelle Montoya's
stay connected with john by visiting
john trevaunance calm stay connected
with Mary now by visiting Marianna
humbler calm and they're both on Twitter
at true gonna sand at Mary now I want to
come back to Judy of mark for a second
you want to follow up on them you can
visit Pelican media org and if you want
to keep up with Mark's writings visit
Mark bit nerd net we'd like to thank our
guy Ronan Rosner he's the sort of our
radio angel technician here at LA talk
radio he's always watching over us here
the studio is also the architect behind
film cares calm and until next Sunday
have a great week